Alright, I'm going to hit you with a definition first.
>> Hit me.
>> So, conditional independence is this idea that goes
like this. We're going to say that some variable that
makes up the joint distribution is conditionally independent of
some other variable, Y, given Z, if it's the
case of the probability distribution governing X, so the
probabilities associated with the values in this variable X
Is independent of the value of y given the value of z. So if I tell you what
z is, then you can figure out what the probability of x
is without having to look at y. So that is, if it's
the case that for all possible values, little x, little y and
little z for the variables big x, big y, and big z, If
it's the case that the probability that big X, the random variable
big X, equals, takes on the value of little x, given that
big Y takes on the value of little y and big Z
takes on the value of little z, equals the probability that big X
takes on the value of x given big Z takes
on the value of z. If those are equal for all
possible ways of filling in the values of the variables,
then we say that x is conditionally independent of y given
z. Right, so you see we dropped Y from the
right-hand side of the probability expression. Okay, so it's sort of
less things we have to worry about, if it's the
case that we really didn't need it in the first place.
>> Fewer.
>> Fair enough.
>> So that's pretty similar
to normal independence. Okay, so what's normal independence?
>> So normal independence, we say the probability of x and y
is equal to the probability of x times the probability of y.
>> That's right.
>> Which means if we think about the chain rule, we
also know that the probability of x and y is equal
to the probability of x given y times the probability of
y. So that means that the probability of x given y is
equal to the probability of x, for all values of x and y.
>> So this is actually implying. So [INAUDIBLE] if it
equals that. Oh, that means that P(x) times P(y) equals
P(x given y) times P(y). If we cancel those, we
get px equals. Okay. That's what you wanted to say.
>> Right. So, since, What independence means,
right, is that the joint distribution between two
variables is equal to the product of their
marginals. That's just. You know comes from basic
probability theory and so if you think about what that means
from the chainable point of view it's like saying the probability of
x given y is equal to the probability of x. So,
it looks just like the equation you wrote down for conditional independence.
>> Right, the only thing that we added is this notion that it might
be the case that we don't have such a strong property as this where
it's always the case that you can write the probability of x given y
just with the probability of x. But in the context of some, of knowing
some value z, it might be true. And that's what conditional
independence gives us. As long as there is some z that we
stick in here, that gives us that property, that's great, we can
essentially ignore y, when we are talking about the probability of x.
>> Okay, that's pretty cool. That means more powerful or something.
>> Yeah, and in fact if you remember you mentioned the
word factoring. You can see here that we are down a
probability as the product of two other things. We are factoring
that probability distribution. That's what
independence let's us do. And conditional
independence let's us do that in, in more general circumstances. So
let's apply this content back to what we were talking about before.
>> Okay.